la figura a es una copia escala de la
figura ve y luego nos dicen cuál es el
valor de x pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo muy bien dado que la
figura a es una copia a escala de la
figura ve eso también significa que la
figura be es una copia a escala de la
figura
de modo que tendremos un factor de
escala común entre los lados
correspondientes
por ejemplo este lado de aquí parece que
juega el mismo papel que este lado
entonces cuál es el factor de escala
para pasar de 10 a 12.5 que es lo que
tengo que multiplicar por 10 para
obtener 12.5 bueno voy a multiplicar por
un factor de escala
voy a multiplicar por 1.25 o también
podríamos pensarlo como multiplicar por
1 y un cuarto cualquiera de las dos
formas expresa el mismo número
bueno si estoy pensando en x si quiero
conocer esta longitud que tenemos aquí
el lado correspondiente a este lado de
la figura b es este lado de la figura a
que tiene una longitud de 16 de modo que
voy a usar el mismo factor de escala
entonces mi factor de escala aquí será 1
y un cuarto nuevamente lo voy a
multiplicar por 1 y un cuarto y un
cuarto de 16 es igual a 4 entonces esto
es igual a 16 más otros 4 es igual a 20
1.25 por 16 es igual a 20 terminamos
hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos dicen que la figura a es una
copia a escala de la figura ve muy bien
la figura está hecha a partir de la
figura ve usando un factor de escala de
5 medios cuál es el valor de x pausa en
el vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
bueno cuando nos dicen que la figura se
hace a partir de la figura ve usando un
factor de escala de 5 medios eso
significa que cuando hacemos la figura a
si miramos el lado correspondiente de la
figura ve entonces tenemos este lado en
la figura ve que parece que corresponde
a este lado de la figura así que para
pasar de 5 a x deberíamos usar un factor
de escala de 5 medios vamos a
multiplicar por cinco medios bueno
cuánto es 5 por 5 medios dejen
escribirlo aquí x es igual a 5 x nuestro
factor de escala que es 5 medios lo cual
va a ser igual a 25 sobre 2
y si queremos lo podemos escribir como
12.5 de modo que la equis que tenemos
aquí esta longitud es igual a 12.5 hasta
el próximo vídeo